[Musica]
allora pd e vediamo se oggi vuoi
collaborare
dovete scusarci perché questa è la
nostra prima presentazione interattiva e
quindi siamo tutti e due abbastanza tesi
e lo è saluti non saluti ha intenzione
di collaborare oggi dai che abbiamo poco
tempo go to sleep bb eight bibbie it go
to sleep va bene dovete scusare un po
teso allora new d'asti spengo ti spengo
perché dobbiamo parlare di cose serie
vediamo se ci riusciamo dai stai zitto
un pochino
scusateci questo è il mio mondo e questo
è il mio sogno un futuro in cui i robot
saranno fra di noi in ogni campo del
quotidiano e possibilmente ci aiuteranno
in tutti i task della nostra giornata al
lavoro a scuola magari ci aiuteranno a
fare i compiti
però purtroppo questa immagine
abbastanza lontana per il momento
chiaramente perché i robot sono sistemi
complicati dal punto di vista
ingegneristico ma una parte su cui
bisogna fare tanto lavoro ancora è
l'interfaccia perché chiaramente per
poter utilizzare un robot
bisogna avere un'interfaccia intuitiva
senza doversi leggere duemila pagine di
manuale soltanto per accenderlo in
questo momento una tipica interfaccia
per una macchina anche abbastanza
semplice questa disfida utilizzare
questa lavatrice senza aver mai letto il
manuale
vi sfido a utilizzare una delle
lavatrici che abbiamo noi a tokyo senza
avere idea di cosa significano i kanji
che ci sono sopra è chiaramente vi
lascio immaginare quali sono le
interfacce che utilizziamo per robot un
pochettino più complessi ma come
facciamo per costruire un interfaccia
veramente intuitiva e interessante
sapere che da parecchi studi è emerso
che noi tendiamo interfacciarci con le
macchine con i dispositivi in maniera
tanto più naturale come se stessimo
interfacciando con un'altra persona
quanto più questi dispositivi sono
tecnologicamente avanzati sicuramente
per me è stato di grande conforto perché
trovarmi a gridare al gps
quando mi ha portato a spendere chissà
dove mi ha fatto sentire un po stupida
ma scientificamente provato che è una
cosa naturale per noi fare questo
quindi per costruire un interfaccia
intuitiva la cosa migliore sarebbe
partire da come noi ci interfacciamo con
le altre persone quindi abbiamo preso un
modello di interazione umana che come
vedete è un po complesso perché non
soltanto entra in gioco quello che
l'altra persona e di ceo fa nel
costruire la nostra risposta ma è
importante anche l'atteggiamento
dell'altra persona il contesto generale
dell'interazione e questi due
tutti questi fattori sono presi in
considerazione da due progetti processi
paralleli i processi cognitivi e
processi emozionali il processo
cognitivo fondamentalmente è tutto
l'insieme di ragionamenti logici che noi
facciamo è che ci portano a costruire
una risposta diretta sensata
possibilmente logica razionale
all'azione o alla domanda dell'altra
persona i processi emozionali invece non
sempre sono razionali tengono parte di
molti altri fattori di cui certe volte
noi siamo all'oscuro da un punto di
vista
di pensiero e portano a volte a risposte
del tutto impreviste
quindi è importante per costruire
l'interfaccia del tutto intuitiva essere
in grado di interpretare correttamente e
anche rispondere correttamente a
entrambi questi processi
infatti secondo molti studi uno dei più
importanti quello di mehrabian soltanto
il 7 per cento delle dell'interazione è
data da azioni dirette o parole il
linguaggio tutto il resto si svolge in
maniera indiretta tramite il linguaggio
del corpo tramite i cambi di toni di
voce e tutto questo deve essere preso in
considerazione dal robot per essere in
grado di interfacciarsi con noi in
maniera intuitiva e diretta un concetto
interessante per noi robotici sti è il
concetto di uncanny valley o valle
perturbante come tradotto su wikipedia o
magari un po più intelligentemente come
zona del disagio questa teoria afferma
che quanto più un oggetto è simile un
oggetto un robot è simile ad una persona
nel suo nella sua interazione prendendo
in considerazione tutti gli aspetti
dell'interazione non soltanto
l'apparenza fisica il modo di muoversi
in modo di porsi in modo di parlare
quanto più noi tendiamo essere a nostro
agio
proprio come se ci stessi mente
affacciando con una persona normale c'è
però un punto in cui si cade nella zona
del disagio in cui quando questo oggetto
questo robot è molto simile all'uomo ma
uno di questi fattori non è all'altezza
non è come ce lo aspettiamo noi che noi
entriamo sentiamo una sensazione
spiacevole una sensazione di disagio non
riusciamo più a interfacciarci in
maniera corretta e cerchiamo di
interrompere l'interazione
questo è dato da una nostra risposta
emozionale ad un incongruenza
dell'emozione della risposta emozionale
generalmente del robot quindi le
emozioni sono il ponte che ci permette
di superare la zona del disagio e far sì
che riusciamo che i robot riescano a
essere veramente interattivi come noi ce
lo aspettiamo
in sostanza se voi avete letto questo
libro se gli uomini sono da marte e le
donne vengono da venere e devono
imparare a comunicare fra di loro
secondo le aspettative l'uno dell'altro
perché altrimenti non si arriva a un
dialogo
i robot vengono dalla terra e anche loro
hanno bisogno di interfacciarsi con noi
secondo le nostre aspettative in
sostanza per costruire un interfaccia
completamente intuitiva uomo robot il
robot deve essere in grado si di saper
interpretare correttamente e rispondere
secondo sul canale cognitivo a risposta
risposte dirette a domande dirette
risposte dirette a azioni dirette ma
deve essere anche in grado di
interpretare correttamente e rispondere
sul canale emozionale un po più
indiretto un po più sottile e che però
certe volte è completamente opposto al
canale cognitivo
chiaramente i robot devono sapere
interpretare le emozioni per poterci
rispondere correttamente ma non devono
come si pensa
provare emozioni perché proprio perché
le emozioni sono frutto di ragionamenti
processi non tutti non del tutto
razionale possono portare ha risposto
impreviste noi non vogliamo che robot
abbia risposte impreviste noi vogliamo
che il robot risponde esattamente come
noi ce lo aspettiamo per cui non
vogliamo trovarci a litigare con rob
così per cui è importante questa
distinzione
ma da un punto di vista pratico come si
svolge la comunicazione dunque abbiamo
detto che la maggior parte della
comunicazione si svolge su un piano non
verbale
all'interno dei segnali non verbali ci
sono segnali consci che noi facciamo
sapendo di fare e segnale inconsci di
cui non siamo del tutto come si
giustamente dunque questi segnali si
dividono in segnali vocali para
linguaggio tutto quello che non è
linguaggio diretto le esclamazioni i
cambi di toni di voce e poi c'è il
linguaggio del corpo i movimenti inoltre
ci sono segnali del tutto emozionali
segnali che sono gesti codificati gesti
di cui tutti comunque conoscono il
significato basti pensare se il punto in
una certa direzione
a metà fra i gesti codificati e l i
segnali emozionali ci sono i gesti
creativi che sono generalmente
utilizzati nell'arte e che sono gesti
che ne facciamo
sapendo di fare ma che vogliono
esternare una particolare emozione un
robot deve sapere correttamente
interpretare tutti questi segnali e
rispondere correttamente a tutti questi
segnali fisicamente noi come interagiamo
fisicamente noi usiamo il nostro corpo
ci sono parecchi cambiamenti in atto nel
corpo durante l'interazione alcuni
cambiamenti sono visibili l'espressione
facciale
il movimento del corpo alcuni
cambiamenti sono invisibili e
generalmente sono proprio i cambiamenti
dovuti alle risposte emozionali per
esempio cambiamenti nel nel battito
cardiaco nella respirazione la pressione
sanguigna che sale a mille quando uno si
arrabbia eccetera
dunque noi uomini generalmente abbiamo
tutti i cinque sensi che sono pochi ma
sono capaci di interpretare i segnali
molto complessi e con questi segnali
molto comunque si cinque sensi noi
interpretiamo generalmente soltanto la
parte visibile cambiamenti del
corpo quindi le espressioni facciali la
voce cambi di tono di voce i movimenti
del corpo
quindi un robot per essere in grado di
interfacciarsi con noi in maniera
intuitiva deve essere in grado di
muoversi correttamente rispondere
correttamente tono di voce corretto e
fare espressioni facciali in caso abbia
il viso corrette per quanto riguarda i
robot invece ce ne sono tanti tipi di
tante dimensioni di tante forme e
generalmente sono dotati di tantissimi
tipi di sensori diversi che però sono in
grado di processare soltanto segnali
molto semplici per cui per un robot per
costruirsi il più possibile un'immagine
corretta della situazione globale quindi
sia cognitiva che emozionale nostra del
loro partner devono essere in grado di
utilizzare i loro sensori per captare
tutte le variazioni possibili del corpo
della di chi sta interagendo con loro e
quindi fondamentalmente io sono
diventata la psicofisiologo come
dicevano ieri dei robot interessante noi
lavoriamo soprattutto con gli umanoidi
per cui abbiamo fatto studi sulla
postura degli umanoidi chiaramente se un
robot vuole esprimere felicità deve
avere una postura corretta se vuole
esprimere tristezza avrà una postura
diversa tutti gli studi sono stati fatti
su persone normali
generalmente su video e applicati a
robot un robot stato diviso umanoide
sempre nostro del nostro laboratorio
deve essere in grado di
produrre espressioni facciali che
assomiglino il più possibile a quelle
che facciamo noi durante le nostre
interazioni emozionali nel caso mio io
lavoro con il robot sassofonista che
deve interpretare in questo video i
gesti creativi della ballerina estrarre
l'informazione emotiva che la ballerina
vuole esprimere e riprodurla con un
mezzo diverso la musica
e adesso per farvi capire quanto in
realtà sia molto più sottile
l'interazione ho portato il mio
assistente che però è un po birichino e
non so se vuole collaborare e questo per
farvi vedere che un robot che non è
umanoide che non ha una faccia che non
ha grandi possibilità di comunicare se
non quello vocale è in grado lo stesso
possibilmente di generare qualche
risposta emotiva vediamo se ce la
facciamo vivi eight sei pronto e lo no
no non ti buttare che già ci hai provato
ieri vuoi salutare la folla si o no è
spaventato e chiaramente perché
veramente la prima volta che i nomi che
noi facciamo una presentazione
interattiva si si si non ti preoccupare
non ti preoccupare però è contento di
essere qui va bene e facciamo ce ne
andiamo saluta tutti ce la facciamo b b
ed avviene grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]